MIDDLE, THESE ARE TWO TEAMS THAT
ARE VERY DEEP ATHYMAN.
THAT WILL BE 23.  AGAIN.
A GREAT PASS BY YAMAMOTO.
FAKES THE SHOT.ON.
THAT'S HIS 22nd.
WE ARE TIED AT
ANGLE, TAKES THIS PUCK.
TOO LATE
HYMAN HAS CASHED IN AONE,
SCANDELLA THAT IS RIGHT THERE.
OFF THE BACKHAND U U
JUSTIN FAULK PLAYED IT WELL.
CAMEWN.
THAT'S HOW YOU KILL A PENALTY
OFF.
KANE GETS H ON THE
FORECHECK.
BARRIE WHACKED THE STICKie: QUI
THAT STAYED OUT.
BRANDON SAAD TRIED TO LINE THAT
CREDIT THE ST. LOUIS BLUES.
ONCE THEY GOT IT IT WAS ROBERT .
McLEOD OUTFOXED AS TIME TO LOAD
SPOT.
MIKE SMITH TOOK A HARD LOOK BET
CLUBS.
HERE'S NURSE.
KANE A
I THINK HUHUEAMS EVER
WON MORE THAN 8 IN A ROW ON HOM
ON THE PLAY COMING INTO THE L
SEASONS HAPPENED THE LAST FOURB
TO KEEP THAT PLAY ALIVE FUNNELED